The correct answer is:
The numeral "1"--the digit--appears.
Let's go ahead and see this, for real.
Okay. Here we are in our browser.
We've got "the number one" selected.
When I click Submit, I see "q" equals the numeral "1"
because that's what we specified in the value parameter.
And if we selected one of these other options--
let's go with "three" this time--
when I click Submit, we see "q" equals the word "three"
because that's what was the contents of the Option parameter.
And if you don't specify a value,
the value of the "q" parameter in the URL will default
to the contents of the Option elements.
So if you want to have a different value in the URL--
that's different from the contents of the Option element--
that's what the value parameter is for.